i'm joined now by natalie elfic the
conservative mp for dover thank you very
much indeed for joining us just firstly
the reaction from your constituency well
everyone is shocked and appalled this
tragedy it felt like it was sadly only a
matter of time before we saw a boat cap
size and that has happened this is a
very compassionate and concerned
community they want to make sure that
people are looked after in places where
they need help but they don't want them
making this dangerous journey where
we're seeing loss of life and of course
do you recognize
the conservative government's role in
this tragedy it's absolutely vital that
the uk and the french government work
together they have been working together
on this and clearly more needs to be
done
i mean the prime minister and the french
president have been talking overnight
and i very much see hope that we'll see
something coming from that about fresh
action on the french beaches now of
course the conservative government very
much won the last election on the issue
of brexit taking back control
is this humanitarian crisis we're seeing
unfold in the channel what taking back
control looks like
what we are seeing across the channel in
small boats crisis is criminal activity
pure and simple we're seeing the people
smugglers preying on vulnerable people
taking their money putting them into
boats and not frankly caring whether
they live or not making this dangerous
journey we've got to tackle it and the
best way to do that is stop the votes
leaving in the first place and keep the
boats keep people safe in france but
surely the government has shown a lack
of care too hasn't it it's taken 27
people to die for president macron and
boris johnson to pick up the phone to
each other and promise urgent action
well there's been really good working
together with the french and what are
called the juxtaposed controls the legal
controls between britain and france for
a very long time now and that sees
french border officers here and it sees
british border officers over in calais
i want to see an extension of that
approach on these illegal routes and for
it to be tackled i think in terms of the
uk government's commitment to the issue
it has sent you know now hundreds of
millions of pounds to the french over
the last few years it's provided
surveillance drones it's provided
intelligence has joint intelligence
sharing and there has been for some time
so there is a lot of work from the uk
government with the french government
but the key thing which was turned down
were people on the beaches to make sure
that these boats were stopped getting in
the water and that's got to change
france has to accept help from britain
and the rest of the eu if we're going to
see an end to these sorts of tragedies
now speaking of the eu of course you're
a supporter of brexit and under the
so-called dublin convention
uh refugees had to apply for asylum at
the first safe country they reached of
course that no longer applies to the uk
because we're no longer in the european
union
has brexit made things worse
i think what we're seeing is that people
are being encouraged by these criminal
gangs to continue on their journey when
they're already in a safe place and it's
absolutely vital that people take the
opportunity to be safe and to stay in a
place of safety it isn't safe to cross
the english channel it isn't safe to get
in a rickety dinghy and it isn't safe to
travel in the wintery seas and that's
what we've seen so this is about
criminal activity and people smuggling
and it's also about making sure that
actually if people do come into the
country unlawfully that they are
returned only in this way are we going
to see an end to this type of activity
and just briefly the times is reporting
more than 600 migrants arrived here
yesterday alone what numbers are you
hearing is very large numbers again
yesterday we've had 25 000 arrivals now
getting off for 26 000 arrivals
yesterday specifically yesterday
specifically i haven't had a confirmed
number i think it is in the hundreds as
you mentioned